CONFIDENCE.
>> Brendan: THESE TWO
BUT ON NET.
SO NO ICIN
>> Brendan: BUCHNEVICH.
PERRON.
SHORT SIDEN
HOUR SLAP SHOT, BUT DOWN LOW% I
REGULAR SEASON AND UP TO 49% IN.
>> Brendan: SHOT B
GETS SET UP THE FACEOFF.
BUCHNEVICH TO THE POINT.E IT
SINCE JUNIOR.
NO NEED TOSIGNIFICANT NEWS HERE.
LAST WAS THE FIRST OF TH THE
CONFIDENCE THAT IF H
BORTUZZO OFK
SAAD HAD A GREAT CHANCE.
DEFENSIVELY.
>> Darren: ALL I KNOW, SHANE, WE
HE WAS LEGALLY ABLE TO PLAY IT.
>> Brendan: KYROU SCOOOORES!D R
>> Shane: JORDAN KYROU IS
BURAKOVSKY KEEPS IT IN.A GOOD G
SAVE, ,
SWATTED AHEA.
HERE'S SHANE, IS THE
.
PERRON, HE'LL SHOOT, SCOOORE!  N
5 ON 3
COLORADO IS 5-0 TO START THIS
POPO
HIS PASS STOLEN AWAY.
RANTANEN ON A NOT SURE WHERE TH.
AND A GREAT SAVE B
IT CAME RIGHT BACK TO LANDESKOG
SIDE OF THE NET AND HEEY TURN I.
IT'S TWO-ON-ONE.
K
GOES THE OTHER WAY.
>> Shane: YEAH, BURAKOVSKY
GO.
PUT GAME TWO AWAY!NDESKOG'S GOT.
S BLOCKING SHOTS.
>> Brendan: 45 SECONDS LEFT.